That, I'm convinced, puts some kind
of a psychological pressure on us
and it can feel lonely at times.
Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here.
Today I'm going to talk about a subject
that doesn't come up very often.
It's loneliness, loneliness
and language learning.
Remember if you like these
videos, please subscribe, click
on the bell for notifications.
If you follow me on Apple Podcasts or
Spotify or other podcast services, I'd
appreciate it if you could leave a review.
So, first of all, I have
received some comments to the
effect that my sound is too low.
So I've worked on the orientation
of my microphone here, and
hopefully this is better.
Uh, loneliness.
So it's a subject that never comes up.
We think of language learning.
We're learning to communicate with people.
We're gonna make new friends, we're
going to connect with new cultures.
So it's, it's, it's wonderful.
And, and of course, language is, is not
only a means of communicating meaning.
Language is a means of
connecting with people.
I've even seen the theory that the
first humanoids developed language as
a means of sort of social grooming.
It almost doesn't matter
what we're saying.
We just want to hear
other people's voices.
We say something so they can hear
our voices and we're just connecting.
And that serves a need, a social need
that we have to connect with other people.
Now when we're learning languages, of
course we can be in a classroom with
other people where we are connecting
socially, but at some point to learn
the language we have to connect with
the language we have to listen and read.
As I always say, even if we're listening
to someone or speaking with someone
we're having trouble getting the meaning
because we're working in a new language,
a language that we're trying to learn.
And I have had the experience,
particularly when I learn a language
very intensively like I did with
Chinese, where I was like seven
hours a day in this Chinese world.
Not just casually connecting with
people, not watching movies that I
understood easily in my own language,
not being with friends and family, but
sitting there trying to get my brain
cells to get used to this new language.
And sometimes, and I can remember in Hong
Kong that when I would come out from that
and I would just communicate with people,
sometimes I felt a certain
awkwardness that the, um, this sort
of intensive interaction with a
strange language, forcing the brain
to get used to new language can, you
know, create a sense of loneliness.
You are alone with something that
you don't understand very well.
And like, even now, for example,
you know, my wife might be watching
a movie on Netflix in English or
French a language where, which we
understand and where in any case
there are subtitles for the French.
And it would be nice to just
sit there and enjoy the movie.
But I at some level, I want to
work on my Arabic or my Persian.
And so I go downstairs by myself and
I work on these, uh, whatever they
might be, podcasts or other lessons
in our LingQ library, where I'm saving
words and phrases, and gradually
trying to get used to the language.
I wander around the house with my
AirPods in my ears, uh, so that I
can take advantage of whatever time I
have that I'm cleaning up or something
to get more of the language in me,
I want to sort of force a change of
transformation of my brain so that I
can easily deal with this language.
That, I'm convinced, puts some kind
of a psychological pressure on us
and it can feel lonely at times.
And so there are these ways in which sort
of intensive language learning affects us.
Now that's no different than any other
pursuit that we go at sort of intensively,
and there was a movie called The
Loneliness of the Long Distance R,unner.
I don't know much about the movie I
gathered it had to do with social classes
in English, but anything you do, you
know, with intensity, whether it be as
a piano player or as a, uh, you know,
a performance athlete or whether you're
pursuing, you know, a science or whatever.
You as an individual sort of striving
to acquire knowledge or skills in a
particular field, and you're shutting
yourself off from other people that
can create a sense of loneliness.
Now, there are many ways that we can,
you know, interact with other people,
whether we're in science class or
whether we have teammates or language
class, or the people I talk to online.
And I cherish the uh, sessions that
I have, I was with, uh, Adel Samy of
Egypt this morning, and he's taking
me through Egyptian Arabic and those
are wonderful moments and those are
social moments, but there's also a
lot of time when it's, it's lonely.
It's just the learner and the language.
And I just want to mention that because
it's something people should be aware of.
They shouldn't consider it strange
that at times they feel lonely
in their pursuit of the language.
And it's important to remember that
ultimately the reward is great.
So I now communicate comfortably in
Chinese, Japanese, French, Russian,
languages that I learned a while ago.
And, uh, I even finding now that
I'm able to communicate fairly
comfortably in Persian with, with
Sahra, Persian being easier than Arabic.
Now I've completely confused myself
in Arabic because I've started
into Egyptian Arabic, which is fun
because it's a, it's a country where
they speak the language, egypt is.
Whereas there is no country that speaks
Standard Arabic, but it has kind of caused
both of them to get further confused.
And so I got a struggle with
that and I'm struggling with
it, uh, you know, on my own.
So there is a certain loneliness
attached to language learning.
Until you get to a stage where we
are comfortable communicating and we
kind of rejoin the world around us.
So just a thought that I had
that I wanted to share with you.
Bye for now.